Este fue el hombre clave en la política exterior
norteamericana de la segunda mitad del siglo
XX.
Asesor de Seguridad Nacional primero y Secretario
de Estado después con Richard Nixon, Henry
Kissinger fue considerado durante años como
la cara pública de la realpolitik, el pragmatismo
por encima de todo.
Amado por unos y señalado por otros, sus
decisiones dieron forma no solo a la política
exterior norteamericana sino también al mundo
que conocemos.
Kissinger fue uno de los grandes artífices
de la apertura de relaciones entre Estados
Unidos y la República Popular China, el fin
de la guerra de Vietnam y la puesta en marcha
de las negociaciones de paz entre Israel y
Egipto.
Un proceso que años después culminaron con
los Acuerdos de Camp David.
El primer gran acuerdo de paz entre Israel
y un país árabe.
Pues bien, el pasado 27 de mayo de 2023 Kissinger
cumplió 100 años…
Motivo por el cual en VisualPolitik hemos
querido preparar este vídeo.
Nos puede gustar más o menos su figura, pero,
sin duda, Kissinger fue uno de los grandes
protagonistas de la política internacional
de todo el siglo XX.
Sin él el mundo de hoy sería muy diferente.
Quizás mejor o quizás peor, pero en cualquier
caso muy diferente.
Y por eso con este vídeo queremos responder
unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Realmente quién fue Kissinger y que representó
exactamente para el equilibrio de poder de
la Guerra Fría?
¿De qué forma contribuyó a dar forma a
nuestro mundo?
¿Cuáles fueron sus grandes aciertos y cuáles
sus grandes errores?
Pues bien, en este vídeo vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas.
Arranquemos.
[Por cierto, antes de empezar, dejadme que
os haga una pregunta: ¿has utilizado ya algún
servicio o app de inteligencia artificial?
Seguro que sí.
La IA ha irrumpido en nuestras vidas como
un rayo…
Lo que quizás no veamos a simple vista es
la enorme guerra que se ha desatado entre
empresas y también gobiernos de todo el mundo
por liderar esta carrera.
No lo dudeis éi ni un segundo, la IA puede
ser decisiva, por ejemplo, en la disputa que
mantienen China y Estados Unidos por la hegemonía
mundial.
Y no solo eso, la IA también puede terminar
afectando a millones y millones de puestos
de trabajo.
Por tanto hay una cuantas preguntas que nos
tenemos que hacer:
¿Quién liderará esta carrera?
¿Qué impacto económico tendrá?
¿Destruirá tantos empleos como se dice?
Te contamos todas las respuestas en Si lo
Hubiera Sabido, el canal de información financiera
de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.]
Y ahora sí, sigamos.
Año 1969.
Estados Unidos tiene en su inventario más
de 26.000 armas nucleares, miles de bases
militares repartidas por toda Europa y numerosas
flotas repartidas por los mares del mundo.
Todo está preparado para luchar contra el
imperio rojo.
La Guerra Fría atraviesa sus años más difíciles
y en ese momento el mundo era un lugar peligroso.
Y no solo hablamos del posible armagedón
nuclear.
También del choque entre India y Pakistán,
el creciente caos en América Latina, la descolonización
de África o el conflicto árabe-israelí,
entre muchos otros.
Además, la caída en la Unión Soviética
de Nikita Jrushchov en 1964 y su recambio
por Leonid Brézhnev supuso el regreso a una
línea más dura y la pausa de cualquier distensión.
Prácticamente, podemos decir que el mundo
se había convertido en un enorme barril de
pólvora.
Cualquier mecha lo podía hacer estallar en
mil pedazos.
Había que evitarlo, tocaba echar el freno
y reducir la tensión…
Pero la pregunta es…
¿Cómo?
Amigos, en noviembre de 1968, el republicano
Richard Nixon ganó las elecciones presidenciales.
Le tocaba entonces escoger al nuevo guía
de la política internacional..
Justo ahí fue cuando comenzó la era Kissinger.
Pero no vayamos tan rápido.
(A quien todos conocemos como “Henry”
Kissinger, en realidad nació bajo el nombre
de Heinz Alfred Kissinger, un 27 de mayo de
1923, en Baviera, Alemania, solo 10 años
antes de que el nazismo llegara al poder.
Su familia era judía-alemana, así que la
llegada en 1933 de Adolf Hitler al poder cambio
sus vidas para siempe.
Las medidas de segregación nazis fueron poco
a poco expulsándoles de la vida civil hasta
que finalmente, en 1938, cuando Kissinger
tenía 15 años, su familia consiguió huir
de Alemania, primero a Reino Unido y luego
a EE. UU.)
Concretamente a Nueva York, donde terminaría
matriculandose en el City College para estudiar
la carrera de contabilidad.
Sea como sea, en 1943 adquirió la nacionalidad
norteamericana y ese mismo año fue reclutado
y enviado al frente europeo, donde gracias
a saber hablar alemán y tener acento local
terminó como comandante del destacamento
del Cuerpo de Contrainteligencia del distrito
de Bergstrasse de Hesse.
Lo que sí lo pensáis bien supuso un sorprendente
giro en los acontecimientos.
Kissinger que había llegado con su familia
huyendo de Alemania como un judío perseguido,
había regresado a su país natal convertido
ya en ciudadano estadounidense con la misión
de pelear en una guerra abierta contra el
régimen nazi.
Vaya vueltas que da la vida…
Con todo lo más trascendente estaba aún
por llegar.
(Cuando Kissinger volvió a Estados Unidos
algo en él había cambiado: ya no quería
estudiar contabilidad.
Toda su vida había estado profundamente condicionada
por decisiones políticas y ahora su pasión
por esta actividad se había encendido de
forma irreversible.
Y como decimos por aquí, dicho y hecho.
En 1950 se graduó con honores como licenciado
en ciencias políticas por la Universidad
de Harvard.
Pocos años después obtendría su doctorado
en esta misma universidad.)
Y así, poco a poco se fue incorporando a
los círculos que daban forma a la política
internacional del país.
Kissinger hizo trabajos para el Consejo de
Relaciones Exteriores, el Departamento de
Estado y la Corporación RAND.
Sin embargo, el rol que le acercaría de forma
clave al poder fue la oferta que recibió
para trabajar como asesor de política exterior
de las campañas presidenciales de Nelson
Rockefeller, entonces era gobernador de Nueva
York y oponente en las primarias republicanas
de un tal Richard Nixon.
Kissinger se estaba situando a las puertas
del poder…Pero aún no estaba dentro.
T1 (UN MUNDO EN LLAMAS)
El 5 de noviembre de 1968, Richard Milhous
Nixon ganó las elecciones presidenciales,
se convertiría en el trigesimoséptimo presidente
de los Estados Unidos en un mundo que era
de todo menos un lugar apacible y tranquilo.
Y no, no estoy exagerando.
Si hoy la guerra de Ucrania parece un conflicto
capaz de sacudir los cimientos del orden internacional,
imaginémonos por un momento cuál era la
situación a los finales de los años 60s:
Estados Unidos ya había perdido cerca de
17.000 soldados en Vietnam, la Unión Soviética
había decidido invadir Checoslovaquia y Oriente
Medio era un polvorín tras la guerra de los
seis días y el triunfo del nacionalismo egipcio.
Y por supuesto, entre medias, miles y miles
de cabezas nucleares capaces de hacer estallar
el mundo.
Por si fuera poco, el asesinato del presidente
Kennedy, el movimiento contra la guerra de
Vietnam y la lucha definitiva contra la segregación
racial estaban generando fuertes tensiones
dentro de la sociedad norteamericana.
Este, amigos, era el contexto al que se enfrentaba
el nuevo presidente republicano Richard Nixon.
(Tras su victoria electoral, Nixón invitó
a Kissinger a sus oficinas de Nueva York para
conocerle más de cerca.
La reunión debió de ir muy bien, porque
apenas unas pocas semanas después, Nixon
le ofreció a Kissinger ni más ni menos que
el cargo de asesor de seguridad nacional,
el segundo puesto de mayor rango en el gabinete
que no requería confirmación del Senado.
El primero era el del, propio, jefe de gabinete.)
Claro que la expectación que Kissinger había
generado en Nixon no parecía recíproca.
Para que os hagáis una idea, esto fue lo
que le dijo a nuestro protagonista su antiguo
jefe, el gobernador Nelson Rockefeller.
C1 (“Me reprendió por posponer mi decisión
y me instó a aceptar de inmediato la oferta
de Nixon; cuando el presidente te invita a
un servicio importante, observó, la demora
no es una respuesta adecuada.
"Ten en cuenta", agregó Rockefeller, "que
Nixon está corriendo un riesgo mucho mayor
contigo de lo que tú estás corriendo con
él".
Esa misma tarde llamé por teléfono a Nixon.”
Henry Kissinger, en su libro “Liderazgo:
Seis estudios sobre estrategia mundial”.)
Nuestro protagonista de hoy ya tenía su plaza
en lo más alto del poder.
Aquí es cuando empieza de verdad toda esta
historia.
Atentos.
T2 (3 GOLES POR TODA LA ESCUADRA)
En agosto de 1968, en plena campaña electoral
norteamericana, Leonid Breznev ordenó una
intervención militar sobre Checoslovaquia
después de que este país, miembro del Pacto
de Varsovia y liderado por el presidente Alexander
Dubček, anunciará un paquete de reformas
para la liberalización económica y política.
Algo que la Unión Soviética no estaba dispuesta
a consentir.
Por aquel tiempo la superpotencia comunista
estaba atravesando lo que en Washington denominaban
como el “Estancamiento brezhneviano”.
La economía soviética había comenzado a
mostrar sus primeras grandes grietas y ya
no era capaz de seguirle el paso a Estados
Unidos.
Pues bien, pese a la invasión de Checoslovaquia,
Kissinger consideró que era el momento perfecto
para promover un acercamiento.
Su tesis es que Estados Unidos no tenía que
buscar hacer “leña del árbol caído”
con los problemas soviéticos, sino aprovechar
el momento para lograr pequeños cambios.
Esto es lo que explica la visita del antiguo
líder de la Rumanía comunista, Nicolae Ceaușescua
Washington en 1969, y las posteriores visitas
de Nixon a Yugoslavia, Polonia y naturalmente
también Moscú en múltiples ocasiones.
Y lo cierto es que esta estrategia en cierta
forma funcionó: las relaciones mejoraron
y en 1971 se logró la firma del tratado SALT
para limitar el arsenal nuclear de ambas potencias.
Claro que la Guerra Fría no era el único
quebradero de cabeza en Washington.
En aquel momento la guerra de Vietnam se estaba
convirtiendo ya en toda una pesadilla: una
guerra interminable, cada vez más costosa
y cada vez más impopular.
Estaba claro que Estados Unidos tenía que
buscar una salida…
Pero, ¿cuál?
Pensad que para cuando Nixon juró como presidente,
EE. UU. tenía más de 500.000 soldados desplegados
en Vietnam.
Era una situación insostenible.
Por eso el nuevo presidente le encomendó
a su gabinete lograr el fin de la guerra y
el retiro de las tropas durante el primer
mandato.
Ya sabéis, la guerra no podía afectar de
ninguna forma a su reelección.
Para 1973, el conflicto ya estaba a punto
de llegar a su fin…
Algo por lo que el revolucionario vietnamita
Le Duc Tho y Henry Kissinger recibieron el
nobel de la Paz, aunque el asiático no lo
aceptó por considerar que el conflicto estaba
aún en curso.
No fue hasta 1975, con la caída de Saigón,
cuando 20 años después y de una vez por
todas este desastre militar y político para
Estados Unidos llegó a su fin.
Amigos, las gestiones para lograr el deshielo
político con la Unión Soviética y su papel
para lograr el fin de la guerra le valieron
a Kissinger un ascenso:
Y menudo ascenso.
Sin abandonar su puesto como asesor de seguridad
nacional, Nixón le dio también la secretaría
de Estado.
De esta forma Henry Kissinger se convirtió
en uno de los personajes más importantes
de toda la historia de la política internacional
norteamericana.
Pocas personas han acumulado tanto peso en
un gabinete.
Algo que la nueva rockstar de la política
internacional de América utilizó para desplegar
lo que hoy se conoce como la “Shuttle diplomacy”.
La diplomacia triangular.
Esto es, buscar la aproximación de dos países
hostiles mediante la intervención de un tercer
actor amigable para las dos partes.
Que fue precisamente, la estrategia que Kissinger
empleó en Oriente Medio.
Y es que veréis, en 1973 - ya os hemos dicho
que ese era un mundo más que movidito - se
produjo también la guer ra de Yom Kipur,
donde Egipto y Siria se lanzaron en tromba
contra Israel.
Pues bien, Kissinger utilizó esa especie
de apuesta triangular para convertirse en
el intermediario entre la jefa de gobierno
israelí, Golda Meir, y el presidente egipcio,
Anwar el-Sadat.
Y no solo eso.
El nuevo líder de la política internacional
de Estados Unidos, también invitó a la Unión
Soviética a la ronda de negociaciones.
Kissinger llegó, incluso, a plantear la posibilidad
de crear una fuerza de la ONU, integrada por
ambas superpotencias, para pacificar las cercanías
al canal de Suez.
La idea no prosperó, pero… ¿tropas de
Estados Unidos y la Unión Soviética codo
con codo?
No me digáis que el tipo no era atrevido.
El caso es que el conflicto de Yom Kipur terminó
en 19 días, y el acercamiento de Israel y
Egipto que promovió Kissinger no sólo devino
en un cese al fuego, sino que culminó con
la visita de Sadat a Israel a finales de 1977,
y los acuerdos de Camp David de 1978, ya bajo
la administración de Carter.
Pero…
Recapitulemos: en apenas 4 años, Kissinger
había logrado la salida de Vietnam, un histórico
acercamiento a la Unión Soviética, un importantísimo
acuerdo nuclear y para colmo, también, el
cese del fuego en el polvorín de Oriente
Medio.
No parece mal resultado para tan poco tiempo…
Sin embargo, esperad un momento, porque su
gran obra, la obra que probablemente ha cambiado
el mundo más que cualquier otra estaba aún
por llegar.
Y sí, naturalmente estamos hablando de China…
¡Atentos!
T3 (CHINA, LA OBRA MAESTRA)
¿Sabéis?
Se suele pensar que la idea de estrechar relaciones
con China fue de Kissinger pero, en realidad,
esta era una apuesta que ya Richard Nixon
había defendido años antes de llegar a la
Casa Blanca…
Fijaos:
C2 (“Desde una perspectiva a largo plazo,
no podemos permitirnos dejar a China para
siempre fuera de la familia de naciones, allí
para alimentar a sus fanáticos, abrigar sus
odios y amenazar a sus vecinos.
No hay lugar en este pequeño planeta para
que mil millones de sus habitantes potencialmente
más capaces vivan en un airado aislamiento.”
“Asia after Viet Nam”, paper publicado
por Richard Nixon en Foreign Affairs.
Octubre de 1967.)
Con todo, Kissinger y Nixon coincidían en
el diagnóstico.Sin embargo, acercarse a Pekín
no resultaba nada fácil
¿Qué pasaría con los compromisos asumidos
con Taiwán?
¿Cómo acercarse a un país tan cerrado y
hostil?
¿Realmente era factible estrechar lazos con
la China de Mao?
Pues digamos que aquí el as de Kissinger
fue también la “Shuttle diplomacy”:
Cuando Ceauşescu visitó EEUU en 1969, Nixon
en persona le pidió que le hiciera saber
al gobierno de Mao que quería establecer
conversaciones entre los dos gobiernos.
Recordemos que, en ese momento Washington
seguía reconociendo a la República China,
esto es a Taiwán, y no a la República Popular
China como la China legítima.
El caso es que el ofrecimiento de Washington
cayó en saco roto.
Por eso al año siguiente Kissinger le pidió
al embajador norteamericano en Polonia que
le trasladará el mensaje al primer diplomático
chino con el que coincidiera.
[Lógicamente, el correo electrónico no era
una opción.
¡Cómo han cambiado las cosas!]
La oportunidad llegaría poco después en
un evento social yugoslavo y gracias a ello
en diciembre de 1970 se produjo el primer
contacto oficial entre Nixon y el premier
chino Zhou Enlai.
Lo que allanó el camino para que, en 1971,
Kissinger realizará visitas secretas a la
China comunista para acordar los términos
de la nueva relación que estaba a punto de
nacer.
C3 (“El viaje secreto se organizó programando
una visita mía a Vietnam, Tailandia, India
y Pakistán.
Una vez en Islamabad, se anunció una indisposición
que explicaría mi subsiguiente ausencia de
dos días como una visita a una estación
de montaña para recuperarme.
Todo el proceso -desde la conversación de
Nixon con Yahya Khan el 25 de octubre de 1970
hasta mi llegada a Pekín el 9 de julio de
1971 duró ocho meses.”
Henry Kissinger, en su libro “Liderazgo:
Seis estudios sobre estrategia mundial”)
Poco después, el anuncio de la visita del
propio Nixón a China abriría una nueva era.
El 25 de octubre de 1971, el Consejo de Seguridad
de la ONU reconoció definitivamente a la
República Popular de China (RPC) como la
auténtica China.
Eso sí, pese a ello, Pekín nunca logró
que EEUU minimizara sus compromisos con Taiwán.
Queridos amigos, amigas, en el caso de China
la posición de Kissinger era que las naciones
con capacidad de fuego no podían vivir al
margen del sistema internacional, de la diplomacia
y del orden global, porque aislarlas terminaría
provocando conductas destructivas.
En ese juego sacrificar el reconocimiento
a Taiwán era algo, digamos, asumible.
Es la cruda definición de lo que conocemos
como realpolitik, una estrategia política
que al igual que el propio Kissinger aglutina
tantos admiradores como detractores.
T4 (LUCES Y SOMBRAS)
Los acuerdos con la Unión Soviética, la
reconciliación con China, el fin de la guerra
de Vietnam, las negociaciones de paz en Oriente
Medio…
Esta es quizás la mejor cara de la apuesta
política de Kissinger.
Otras caras no generan en cambio, tanta admiración.
Por ejemplo, Kissinger no dudó en apoyar
diferentes tipos de guerra sucia y dictadores
con tal de frenar la expansión del comunismo
en América Latina.
N1 (“Henry Kissinger cumple 100 años: el
controvertido Nobel de la Paz que apoyó la
"guerra sucia” que dejó miles de muertos
en América Latina.
BBC)
Esta que vais a ver, por ejemplo, es una frase
muy conocida que Kissinger dirigió al Almirante
argentino César Augusto Guzzetti, canciller
del golpe militar liderado por Jorge Rafael
Videla que se había perpetrado hacía apenas
3 meses:.
C4 (“Si hay cosas que deben ser hechas,
deberían hacerlas rápido.
Pero deben volver rápidamente a los procedimientos
normales".
Henry Kissinger)
Parece claro de lo que está hablando, ¿no
os parece?
Represión y persecución.
La Realpolitik en su máxima expresión.
También fue muy controvertida su política
de ampliar los bombardeos masivos sobre Camboya
y Laos para debilitar al Vietcong antes de
sentarse a negociar.
Pese a todo, una encuesta realizada en 2015
entre académicos norteamericanos lo cataloga
como el secretario de Estado más eficiente
de los últimos 50 años.
Fijaos.
Siguiendo un poco esta misma estela, por cierto,
Kissinger defiende hoy por hoy el diálogo
con la Rusia de Putin.
Pero, sea como sea, si algo está claro es
que pese a sus luces y sombras, y ya seamos
más o menos partidarios de esta forma cruda
de hacer política internacional, en la que
todo vale - incluso abrazarte a los peores
regímenes del mundo . Kissinger contribuyó
a dar forma al mundo que hoy conocemos.
Dicho esto la pregunta es para ti:
¿Qué opinión te merece el legado de Henry
Kissinger?
¿Qué te parece su apuesta por la realpolitik?
¿Consideras que su papel fue bueno o malo?
Déjanos como siempre tus impresiones en los
comentarios y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a Visualpolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
¡Ah!
Importante, no olvides echarle un vistazo
a Si lo Hubiera Sabido.
Un abrazo y hasta la próxiima.